équitable en fait et qui favorise la
production sur notre territoire européen
et pas les batailles entre pays
européens donc oui et se posera la
question des financements vous avez
parfaitement raison de le soulever
ici je voudrais dire deux choses la
première c'est qu'il va y avoir une
révision du cadre financier pluriel qui
peut nous permettre de regarder quels
sont les marges de manœuvre et où la
deuxième c'est je crois que la question
des recettes pour se font de
souveraineté va aller au-delà de ce
qu'on est en train de discuter ici si on
se dit les choses entre nous
un peu plus largement j'imagine il y a à
la fois le choc énergétique lira engie
qui arrive à expiration dans deux trois
ans des investissements pour la
transition énergétique des
investissements pour la transition
numérique
ça va demander
en réalité beaucoup plus que ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur la table donc oui il est
temps de commencer à réfléchir à de
nouveaux instruments y compris sur les
recettes
et puisqu'on parle de dépenses nous
arrivons aussi à la Défense et aux
militaires
je vais vous répondre en trois points la
première chose c'est sur ce qui est
l'Europe militaire et l'embryon d'Europe
de la défense qui à nouveau était
impensable avant la guerre en Ukraine il
faut s'en souvenir là on a trois outils
comme vous le savez on a la facilité
européenne de la paix donc nous avons
parlé tout à l'heure pour acheter pour
renouveler notre stock de munitions et
puis nous avons deux autres instruments
un qui est dédié à la recherche et au
développement avec des financements
communs et un qui va être dédié à la
croissance de l'industrie de défense
l'idée étant évidemment que l'on finisse
par acheter tout européen aujourd'hui
c'est pas possible c'est pas encore le
cas mais c'est un peu ça la souveraineté
c'est aussi d'avoir des outils de
défense qui sont importants d'ailleurs à
cet égard on peut quand même se
féliciter du SCAF
qui va développer un outil de protection
de notre ciel en franco-allemand et un
peu plus large pour les années à venir
donc il y a un aspect industriel sur
lequel on travaille qui n'est pas encore
parfait mais sur lequel il y a vraiment
une volonté commune d'avancer et à ce
stade et en l'absence de tout sur
étagère effectivement on continue
d'acheter aussi américain
la deuxième chose et vous l'avez
mentionné c'est le Royaume-Uni une des
raisons pour lesquelles il était
important d'avoir le Royaume-Uni dans la
communauté politique européenne et c'est
bien évidemment parce qu'on sur
l'énergie et sur la défense on a des
liens très forts et après vous l'avez vu
je crois que depuis l'arrivée de
richissouna qui a comme premier ministre
au Royaume-Uni les relations entre le
Royaume-Uni et l'Union européenne mais
aussi entre le Royaume-Uni et la France
en particulier des relations bilatérales
ils sont en train de prendre un nouveau
tournant il y aura la visite à nos cé
hier de richissonnac à Paris et les
sujets par les sujets évoqués vous
l'avez vu ses publics il y aura bien
évidemment la défense donc je crois
c'est très important ce qui est en train
de se passer en ce moment et puis
au delà je crois qu'il y a une question
implicite dans ce que vous disiez sur
l'articulation entre l'outil Union
européenne et l'OTAN
et là il a toujours été clair notamment
et quand la boussole stratégique a été
mise en place que la défense de l'Union
européenne n'est pas concurrente de
l'OTAN elle a vocation à être
complémentaire de l'OTAN d'ailleurs il y
a déjà des opérations conjointes qui se
passent bien et qui nous permettent de
bénéficier les uns des autres donc je
trouve que c'est un sujet
à la fois passionnant et important
puisque la guerre est à nos portes et je
serai ravi qu'on puisse en discuter un
peu plus en détail une prochaine fois
merci dernière série de questions et je
vais demander peut-être d'idées il y a
André Richard qui doit rejoindre la
séance question je voudrais qui pose sa
question et que vous puissiez le
répondre et ensuite je demanderai
Jean-Michel et Lugat et à Jacques Pernic
de s'exprimer merci beaucoup président
madame la ministre effectivement je suis
pas sûr de pouvoir entendre la qualité
de réponse mais je voudrais vraiment
vous poser trois questions
très courtes la première à mon tour je
voudrais insister sur la nécessité de
mettre en oeuvre des mesures visant à
maintenir soutenir la compétitivité de
nos entreprises compte tenu différentiel
du coup d'énergie avec
les États-Unis notamment aussi bien sûr
compte tenu de son de son ira
je suis bien obligé de vous dire que vu
les réponses que vous avez fait tout à
l'heure en la matière je m'inquiète
quand même un peu parce que
j'allais vous interroger sur les outils
qui vous permettra effectivement de
combattre
réellement sur ce terrain vous nous avez
notamment parlé de l'outil en
tissuration
qui me paraît naturellement un excellent
outil mais quand vous disiez que vous
n'aidiez pas sûr que ce serait mis en
application dans les différents pays
pour cause de entre guillemets
répercussions éventuelle et autres enfin
tout ce que vous nous avez dit moi je
m'inquiète vraiment j'ai j'ai
vraiment le sentiment que les États-Unis
sur ce plan-là ne feront aucun cadeau et
que si nous ne sommes pas à la hauteur
en termes de de réponse européenne ça va
être très très difficile pour nous
entreprises vraiment je vous souhaite
insister là-dessus est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment
une volonté au niveau de l'Union
européenne de lutter en la matière et
dans ce cas là quels outils je répète
moi votre outil en tissu mentionne qu'on
vient bien mais ce qu'il est adopté et
adoptable par chacun
y a-t-il d'autres outils dans dans la
mallette de l'Union européenne le en
deuxième question je vous ai dit que
j'irai très vite vous vous avez entendu
le président
Rapin vous parlez de l'Iran aussi
est-ce que là il y a une volonté très
claire est-ce qu'il y a une volonté de
l'Union européenne de sortir des
discours et de prendre des mesures type
fortes concrètes telles que pêle-mêle
mais vous allez les trouver dans le
projet de proposition de résolution qui
qui peut-être vous sera soumis et dont
la Commission les affaires européennes
ici et saisies est-ce qu'il est type GEL
des avoir des autorités iraniennes
impliquées dans dans ce que moi
j'appelle c'est c'est massacres voilà
donc on ne sait d'ailleurs pas tout et
le moins s'en faut est-ce que par
exemple
des mesures pourraient être prises
ça vise sa vise des autorités iraniennes
mais ça peut aussi viser l'état Liban
madame
la ministre lorsque j'entends dire que
des enfants de de taliban haut placé
sont accueillis en France en qualité
étudiants c'est assez amusant ça ils
interdisent à leur fille de suivre des
études là-bas mais il nous les envoie
chez nous bon est-ce que est-ce que
des mesures peuvent être prises à
l'égard au niveau européen à l'égard
d'étudiants iraniens fils enfant de
d'autorité iranienne qui se livre
aux exactions que vous connaissez etc
bref est-ce qu'il y a des mesures
concrètes précises qui pourraient être
prises de façon consensuelle par l'Union
européenne
dans ce qui concerne considéré enfin
unanimement comme étant
un drame dans ce pays et enfin dernier
point asile migration est-ce que j'ai
bien compris que c'est un point qui sera
à l'ordre du jour du prochain conseil
mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
un point sur les avancées à l'égard du
pacte
à nouveau directeur de directeur de
Frontex a enfin été désigné est-ce que
enfin on va avancer je sais que c'est
pas facile à la ministre c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas une critique c'est pas un
procès qui vous est fait certainement
pas mais la France avait avec la
présence française poussait pousser
pousser est-ce que ça avance parce que
vous avez compris que si demain on est
saisi d'un projet loi si on est saisi
d'un projet de loi immigration ça risque
d'être un cataplasme sur une jambe de
bois si effectivement les migration
clandestine continue celle qu'elle est à
l'heure actuelle donc même complexe nous
dit que à l'heure actuelle elle a
retrouvé des niveaux
qu'on n'avait pas connu depuis
maintenant des années voilà où est-ce
qu'on en est et est-ce qu'on avance
parce que c'est un vrai souci ça
merci
vous êtes gentil
merci président une question une
question très très rapide puisque non je
verrai vos réponses dans le contrôle
mais très très rapide suite à l'accord
donc qui est intervenu dans le cadre de
l'OCDE les 27 sont enfin tombés d'accord
donc le 15 décembre dernier sur
l'introduction d'un impôt minimum de 15%
pour les entreprises qui présentent donc
un chiffre d'affaires supérieur à 750
millions d'euros
l'adoption vous le savez de ce
dispositif n'a pas été sans doute
sculpter avec notamment les véto de la
Hongrie et de la Pologne qu'il a fallu
lever donc on vient pas sur les
conditions c'est adoption donc
laborieuse qui a conduit d'ailleurs un
accord à minima nous incite à nous poser
la question justement pour qu'en matière
fiscale alors que plusieurs négociations
importantes vont avoir lieu en 2023
l'on puisse procéder donc à la règle de
l'unanimité
enfin on puisse passer pardon de la
règle de l'unanimité à celle de la
majorité qualifiée donc la France
compte-t-elle porter cette ambition et
quels sont selon vous les verrous pour
enclencher ce qu'on pourrait appeler
cette clause passerelle
oui donc je suis d'être rapide et
d'éviter les redites donc mais quand
même parmi les les actions positives je
voulais relever on l'a évoqué le blocage
des plus de 6 milliards d'euros destinés
à la Hongrie pour ouvrir la sonde à
droite c'est vrai que dans le contexte
qu'on connaît de scandale de corruption
au parlement européen ce qui renforce la
méfiance etc cette avancée et c'est
possible résultat sont bienvenus en
revanche sur les décisions du marché du
conseil sur le marché carbone là je suis
assez déçu parce que la fin des quotas
gratuits ramener seulement enfin
reporter seulement à 2034 de fait c'est
pas ce qui incite les industries
polluantes évoluer vite et puis le
nouveau marché carbone
étendu au transport et au chauffage des
bâtiments je regrette que finalement les
particuliers n'en soient pas exonérés
est-ce qu'on risque pas par là de
générer passer moi l'expression une
sorte d'effet gilet jaune et est-ce que
le fond social pour le climat qui a
quand même été à Moinerie par rapport à
ce qui était attendu et
décalé à 2026 je crois est-ce que ça
sera vraiment mesure de l'empêcher sur
les énergies renouvelables j'avoue pas
tout à fait comprendre la cohérence du
positionnement français parce que ici
gouvernement au Sénat à l'Assemblée
nationale la ligne c'est l'accélération
alors que le gouvernement français au
niveau européen il fait partie de ceux
qui s'opposent fortement à l'objectif de
45% de renouvelables à l'horizon 2030
enfin à la COP15 côté mer et océan il y
a des négociateurs européens qui ont
poussé pour autoriser l'ouverture de
l'extraction minière dans les airs
protégées et j'ai pas compris qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de réaction de la France qui
s'en est pas démarqué pourtant le
Président de la République avait annoncé
en novembre que la France s'opposait à
l'exploitation minière dans les fonds
marins
bon il pouvait pas défendre cette ligne
à la COP15 parce qu'il était au Qatar
merci de nous dire si la bonne position
française est vraiment destinée à être
concrètement tenu
alors si vous me autorisez donc je vais
commencer par
sénateurs
pour soutenir la compréhensitivité des
entreprises je crois pas que vous
devriez vous inquiéter monsieur le
sénateur parce que il y a une volonté
absolument partagée par les 27 de
répondre à cette infection de
réductionnale c'est d'avancer le plus
vite possible à la fois sur la réforme
du marché de l'électricité pour faire
baisser les prix et sur la transition
pour augmenter les capacités de
production des renouvelables et
compenser ainsi ce que nous nous sommes
en train de perdre sur les les énergies
fossiles c'est dans la tête de tout le
monde et un guide pour les actions que
cette prévisibilité que nous devons aux
entreprises sur les prix de l'énergie et
à nouveau je crois que nous avons avancé
à marche forcée à coup d'articles 122 ce
qui veut dire que l'examen au Parlement
n'a pas lieu comme d'habitude c'est pas
très bien pour la démocratie mais ça
répond à l'urgence et l'urgence pour
préserver nos entreprises la deuxième
chose c'est le consensus sur le fait de
devoir stratégiquement soutenir et
développer nos industries alors une pour
nous citer que trois domaines il y a
évidemment la les industries et les
capacités de production industrielles
pour faire de l'énergie propre un
bacarbone et renouvelable ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
tout ce qu'être au numérique je vous
rappelle que le TIPS actes c'est 43
milliards c'est pratiquement autant que
ce que mettent les États-Unis sur la
table et la troisième chose
j'en ai rajouté deux le cyber et la
santé depuis que nous nous sommes parlés
il y a maintenant trois usines en Europe
qui fabriquent du doliprane et des
antibiotiques dont une en Autriche qui
fait des principes actifs donc on est
véritablement en train de changer les
entreprises ont aussi à bouger parce que
pour que ces entreprises de production
d'énergie renouvelables
bas carbone ou de production de
médicaments soit rentable il faut qu'il
y ait une demande donc il va falloir
qu'elle qu'elles av et c'est
particulièrement le cas pour tout les
matériaux critiquent dernière chose il y
a zéro et Adam sur le fait qu'il faut
absolument renforcer accélérer et
renforcer ses capacités industrielles à
la fois européenne les pieds aujourd'hui
comme vous savez sont d'État national la
question d'un top up européen va être
sur la table et je crois que nous allons
le pousser
je pense que ce qui devrait vous
rassurer monsieur le sénateur et la
rapidité avec laquelle l'Union
européenne finalement agit depuis la
crise covid elle a été rapide pour
prendre des mesures elle était rapide
pour l'achat des vaccins on a été rapide
pour faire face aux chocs énergétique de
la crise en Ukraine rapide pour prendre
des sanctions rapides pour délivrer du
matériel militaire rapide pour le
soutien financier et extrêmement rapide
pour le soutien humanitaire j'espère que
je réponds à votre question sur l'Iran
je voudrais dire deux choses
la première chose c'est d'abord que
trois trains de sanctions ont été
adoptées contre les responsables de la
répression et un autre train de sanction
est à l'étude pour le prochain conseil à
faire étrangère qui aura lieu la semaine
prochaine ou la semaine suivante donc
nous continuons sur la voie des
sanctions et nous continuerons aussi
longtemps que le régime sans faire à
dans la voie de la répression et avec
des sanctions de plus en plus dures nous
sommes aussi
nous avons à être responsables il y a
des otages en Iran et donc nous marchons
sur une ligne de crête entre durcir les
sanctions et condamner évidemment tous
ces appels tout tout ce qui se passe en
Iran qui est absolument révoltant et
même moi avec mes homologues ministres
des Affaires européennes nous avons fait
une lettre appelée condamnée donc on
nous allons continuer sur les sanctions
nous allons aussi continuer de protéger
de s'assurer que l'on protège la vie de
nos otages vous conviendrait avec moi
j'en suis sûr que c'est également
important
sur l'Afghanistan je vous reviendrai vu
que tout le monde est scandalisé vous
avez vu les réactions et pas que sur le
travail des femmes dans les ONG je pense
qu'on ne peut être que scandalisé
d'opprimer les femmes de l'âge de la
naissance à l'âge de leurs études elle
ne peuvent même plus aller voir de
médecins puisqu'elles n'ont pas le droit
d'aller voir de médecin homme et que les
médicaments n'ont pas le droit de faire
d'études je crois que c'est la chose la
plus révoltante que j'ai jamais entendu
sur le packaging migration c'est au
programme de la présidente suédoise
comme vous savez
d'avancer sur deux choses à la fois sur
un meilleur filtrage à l'entrée des
migrants et ensuite sur un meilleur
suivi dans l'Union européenne pour
éviter ce qui arrive aujourd'hui parfois
des doubles inscriptions ou des triples
inscriptions donc ça c'est le
renforcement cet aspect renforcement des
contrôles après l'aspect solidarité que
nous avions fait dans l'étape 1 du pacte
c'est vrai que les flux sont importants
et c'est vrai aussi on l'a vu on a eu le
drame de l'océan Viking et ça c'est un
autre éléments que je voudrais
donc je voudrais parler avec vous c'est
que suite à ce drame a été mis en place
un groupe de contacts qui regroupe les
États membres et les organisations non
gouvernementales les ONG de façon à ce
que ce drame ne se reproduit plus et que
les bateaux qui arrivent le phase dans
des conditions correctes et en
répartissant la charge sur Union
européenne on a dans l'idée qu'à un
moment il faudra probablement discuter
d'un code de bonne conduite aussi pour
les ONG en accord avec les pays mais
déjà le fait qu'ils se groupent de
contractes ça n'arrivera pas et oui tout
le monde veut avancer sur le packaging
immigration troisième point
qui gagne en importance et qui sera
discuté probablement conseiller européen
des 9 10 février si les relations avec
les pays de départ vous avez sans doute
en mémoire ce qui s'était fait avec la
Turquie qui permet à la fois de sauver
des vies et c'est donc important et de
faire attention aux frontières sans
drames à nouveau donc nous sommes en
train de réfléchir à comment accentuer
l'aide
au pays de départ et notamment les
positions de développement économique
dans l'aide au développement qui va
permettre de créer des meilleures
conditions pour que ces personnes vivent
dans leur pays et s'y développent plutôt
que risque la noyade dans la mer et puis
nous avons à nouveau chef de Frontex une
d'ailleurs et
je crois que c'est bien que cette agence
soit reprise en main et puis se
développer
monsieur
le deuxième enfin vous m'avez parlé à la
fois du deuxième pilier de la taxe aussi
dese et de la majorité qualifiée la
France apporté et avec l'Allemagne dans
toutes les réunions du conseil à faire
générale
l'avance des progrès une volonté de
progrès sur la flexibilité des
procédures européennes vous avez raison
c'est trop long c'est trop long trop
difficile trop soumis aux aléas d'un
seul pays éventuel donc nous le faisons
sur la politique fiscale
certains le font sur la politique
étrangère aussi
pour ne pas être bloqué par exemple dans
les sanctions dont nous venons de
discuter également et nous allons porter
nous portons une approche équilibrée en
fait faisant un filtrage des domaines
sélectionnent en interne ministériel sur
lesquels nous pensons qu'il serait utile
de passer à cette majorité qualifiée et
à nouveau au Conseil franco-allemand du
22 janvier
on va beaucoup parler de ça aussi et je
serai ravie de revenir vous voir une
fois que c'est sorti merci
je ne vais pas vous oublier monsieur
vernis
sur
merci de ce que vous avez dit sur la
Hongrie d'abord pour commencer j'ai
comme vous qui c'est un bon équilibre
entre reconnaître mais s'assurer aussi
qu'on ne donne pas de chèque en blanc
la fin des côtes à gratuit reporté à
2034 et c'est d'abord je crois que le
signal prix reste et c'est important et
la ligne est toujours la même et c'est
important aussi
c'est côté gratuit c'était une
protection pour nous entreprises ils
vont être remplacés par le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
quand il sera en place et comme vous
savez il y a cette période de trois ans
pendant laquelle on va piloter le
mécanisme pour voir comment il
fonctionne et éventuellement le corriger
je crois qu'on peut que se féliciter que
pour une fois en face des choses on les
évalue et on avance plus loin
le rythme de réduction des quotas
gratuits il est comme je le disais donc
lié à la mise en place du macf d'où les
sur le marché carbone sur le ménage
je crois que
il y a un message qui est
il y a deux choses tout le monde est
convaincu moi la première on ne peut pas
avancer sur la décarbonation sans
emporter la vision politique et
l'engagement des ménages on l'a vu ça
n'est pas possible il y a un principe de
réalité qui s'impose à nous et tout le
monde en est parfaitement conscient on
est aussi conscient qu'il faut qu'on
fasse cette décarbonation donc il faut
qu'on fasse de la voiture thermique à la
voiture électrique on rénove les
bâtiments et ça ça veut dire des
entreprises qui ne feront plus de
voitures thermiques qui ne feront plus
un certain type d'isolation et qui vont
devoir elle aussi évoluer comme les
mines que vous avez mentionnées et donc
il est important d'avoir ce fond social
pour le climat qui va aider à se
transformer
tout ce qui est fait en ce moment et il
faut social pour le climat comme vous
savez il est lié
aussi à cette idée du marché carbone sur
les messages sera évalué si c'est
nécessaire et augmenter si c'est
nécessaire et ajuster si c'est
nécessaire le principe qui je crois
emmener tout le monde dans ces
discussions c'est vraiment ça a donné de
la visibilité entre aux entreprises les
avoir avec nous préserver les emplois
sur le territoire et embarquer les
ménages dans la transition énergétique
ce qui est pas le cas toujours quand
vous avez des ménages qui ont besoin de
leur voiture pas cher pour amener les
enfants à l'école et chez le dentiste
merci
ah pardon il sur les énergies sur les
ENR
non je crois que nous faisons
ce qu'il faut en Europe et
en France
l'objectif de 45% et la façon dont il
est
calculé d'une part par être aux
ambitieux si on est un peu réaliste donc
c'est bien qu'on soit resté sur ça
d'autre part nous avons aussi toujours
ce combat et je vous remercie de l'aider
de nous aider à le porter sur
l'hydrogène faite à partir de nucléaires
sur lequel il faut absolument qu'on
gagne
enfin sur
l'interdiction de l'exploitation des
fond marin que vous avez mentionné
c'est quelque chose qui préoccupe
effectivement la France il y a très peu
d'états dans le monde qui l'ont adopté
aujourd'hui mais il nous avons défendu
cette position tout au long de la Coop
15 et j'espère bien que après
après cette période d'ajustement on y
est on y a on est en fait en 3 décidé de
râler plus de pays parce que pour le
moment il y a pas assez de monde et
notamment avec l'Allemagne avec
l'Espagne avec le Costa Rica le Chili la
Nouvelle-Zélande le wanado et les palots
nous avons
organisé une réunion interministérielle
pour voir comment est-ce que on pouvait
mettre en place cette interdiction de
l'exploitation des fonds c'est un
travail de longue haleine on y arrivera
très bien merci madame la ministre pour
tous ces
retours voilà bon j'ai bien saisi au bon
le fait que vous souhaitiez qu'on se
voit plus souvent donc la commission
sera à votre
probablement demandeuse voilà ce que je
souhaite dire
juste avant vous pouvez disposer ou
rester simplement puisque on a parlé de
la proposition de résolution sur l'Iran
je
elle a été déposée le 4 janvier donc
nous avons jusqu'au 2 février pour
l'étudier et donc elle serait étudiée
dans la séance de commission du 2
février et je propose que ce soit Pascal
Alizard qui en soit le rapporteur pas
d'opposition
merci bien
oui
non par rapport à
des éléments de questionnement de ce
matin
j'ai entendu c'est notre collègue André
Richard qui évoquait effectivement la
situation des enfants de de dirigeants
talibans venant en France etc
dans le cadre des sanctions prises dans
le conflit Russie-Ukraine on a bien vu
que les proches la famille du président
Poutine et d'autres subissaient des
sanctions mais subissent des sanctions
en tant qu'adulte ayant eux-mêmes des
intérêts et je dirais des biens acquis
plus ou moins régulièrement mais mais je
pense qu'on a quand même à faire
attention sur ces sujets là faudrait pas
tomber dans le siphonaphtalmo quand même
et faire payer aux enfants les errements
des parents je sais que c'est un sujet
qui est quand même très sensible mais
mais c'est contraire à tous les
principes de la démocratie et des droits
de l'homme il faut faut quand même qu'on
se fixe une ligne
voilà assez assez précise et qu'on
n'aille pas à l'encontre de nos propres
valeurs sur le sujet
voilà c'est un élément de réflexion
parce que voilà je ce qui se passe en
Afghanistan est intolérable et pas
d'ambiguïté sur le sujet mais il faut
quand même qu'on mesure nous aussi
jusqu'où on est prêt à aller dans les
mesures de rétorsion et ne pas tomber
dans dans ce travers du droit germanique
et nazi
on est complètement d'accord d'autant
que dans le futur ces enfants seront
amenés à avoir des rôles dans leur pays
et que il vaut mieux que ça inspire de
nos valeurs que des valeurs existantes
et belliqueuse